-Our next guest is a talented
actor, you know,
from shows such as "Mad Men,"
"Zoo," and HBO's "Watchmen."
He stars in "Ordinary Joe,"
which airs Mondays at 10 p.m.
right here on NBC.
Let's take a look.
-Great show.
-Yeah, I think I'm going to go
give him another encore, huh?
-Maybe save your energy
for tomorrow night.
-Drink this.
-What's this.
-The organic equivalent
of 18 Gatorades,
with a little
bit of honey for your vocal.
-Mm.
-And a shot of whiskey for fun.
-Or you could just not blowout
your vocal cords.
-Oh, that's good. I love G.
Oh, I'm so happy that you're
here. Oh.
-please, welcome to the show,
James Wolk. How are you, James?
-I'm good. I'm good.
How are you, sir?
-I'm doing well.
I'm hanging in there.
I'm very --
We've never met before.
I'm a huge fan of your work,
and I'm also someone
I feel like has been living
a parallel existence.
You have a 5-year-old
and a 3-year-old.
I have one of each of those
as well.
How have you survived
through the pandemic?
-Oh my. Yeah, we have a
5-year-old boy, Charlie,
and our daughter's
two and a half Lucy Kate.
And it's been like,
it's been a while. It's been --
It's been amazing to have them
to keep us busy
and keep our mind busy
with positive things.
But it's also like being
locked up in the house
with like two lunatics,
24 hours a day.
I don't know
how your experience was.
-You know what we did, we added.
We decided to have another baby
and just it solved everything.
Everybody is super chill now, so
just can't recommend it enough.
-We were thinking about
doing that.
That's exactly
what we were thinking.
-It's a real or real cure-all.
So.
-Yeah.
-I think the thing that a lot of
people did during the pandemic
is they went back, they
revisited old shows they loved.
My wife and I, we just finished
a rewatch of "Mad Men."
So Bob Benson, that's the first
time I ever laid eyes on you.
And I enjoyed it so much more
even in the rewatch,
because it was such a mysterious
character.
You sort of get caught off guard
by him
the first time you watched it.
What was it like
stepping into a show like that
so late into the run
and having such a giant impact?
-Yeah, well,
it was it was really interesting
because I came in in Season 6,
which was the second-to-last
season.
I was on Season 6 and 7
and I was a fan of the show.
Loved the show.
And when I came in, all I knew
was I was playing
this guy named Bob,
he's a new guy in the office.
And the way that Matt Weiner,
the creator, worked
is I would only get the script
for the upcoming episode
the week before.
So I was finding out a lot
about Bob as the series went on.
And so there were so many times
when I read the script
and I was like, "What? He's
speaking fluent Spanish now?"
"What's going on here
with this guy?"
And it actually, as an actor,
it helps a lot
because it didn't allow me
to get ahead of the role
and it allowed me to
kind of play
what I thought he would become.
I kind of had to just stay
in the moment.
But he was he was like an
enigma.
And to me,
as I read each script,
I was just surprised
and it was kind of a cool way
to keep me on my toes.
-It also has one of the most
meme-able moments
in the show's history,
which was --
we-- let's show the clip
for anyone who has
made the mistake of
not watching "Mad Men."
Let's take a look.
-Bob!
-How are you?
-Not great, Bob.
I think about it probably at
least two or three times a week.
I think "Not great, Bob."
about my current situation.
Do people ever say it to you?
-It's crazy because
that has become
something that my friends
will say back to me now.
Like just they,
it's become such a meme.
One of my one of my really dear
friends from New York,
this is a few years ago,
right before the pandemic,
he came out to L.A.,
came out to Santa Monica
and came out with his two sons.
I'm like, I'm going to
take you guys
on an amazing bike ride
on the beach.
You know, you're going
to love that.
So we go on this bike ride.
And one of his sons at the time
was like young,
like three or four, and he
really had to go to the bathroom
"Dad, I have to go,
I have to go."
And so I was like,
"Well, Jay, there's a bathroom
right over there,
you could use the bathrooms
down on the beach, which are
fine.
You know, they're public
bathrooms, which are fine.
And all of a sudden it
from the bathroom.
I hear Jay go, like,
"Don't touch that!"
"Get off the ground.
What are you doing?"
"No!" I literally hear him go,
"No!" like that.
And they come out and without
even thinking about it, I go.
"How did everything go?"
And he looks at me and he goes,
"Not great, Bob!"
Just like, didn't even,
he used it back on me.
And it was it was really funny.
I actually was dying, laughing
because I hadn't been
pulled on me like that before.
-You, you also had
a very nice turn, a villainous
turn on the "Watchmen,"
which was, I feel like
the last water cooler show
before it was no longer healthy
to stand
around the water cooler.
It was that I think
that was another show.
Is it safe to say that
you were probably in the dark
over the course of the series,
knowing where your
character's arc was going to
land you?
-I feel like
that's the thing now,
is I just get cast
and then no one tells me
what's going to happen
to the characters.
That shows that it was actually
something very similar.
I knew I was familiar with the
graphic novel "Watchmen,"
but Damon Lindelof,
the creator,
was very clear that this was
going to be like a remake,
kind of like a retake on it --
and not a remake a retake.
And so this character, Joe Keene
that I was playing
had not been
in any other graphic novels,
and all I knew was that there
was something that wasn't
quite what it seemed with him.
But I had no idea that
by the end of the series,
Can I give a spoiler
if people haven't watched it?
Should I say what happens
at the end or not?
-I feel like enough time has
passed and we have to
punish people
who can't watch shows on time.
I mean, people have had a full
pandemic to catch up.
-Right? Like two years in a
pandemic. So thank you.
So I had no idea that the end
you'd be wearing
just like a black underwear
and explode
into smithereens
in this big machine.
But I remember Damon called me,
he was like, he was like,
"You're doing such great work
in the show.
But I just have to say
to some characters have to die
and he needs to die."
And I totally understood why.
But what a way to go was,
it was the finale.
-It was really, a really great
way to go.
And I guess when you have roles
like Bob Benson or Keene,
it's tough to find a role
that that ticks all those boxes.
And so you went out and you got
a show where you play
three different characters.
Can you,
for anybody who's missed it,
can you just explain the premise
real quick for "Ordinary Joe"?
-Yeah, absolutely.
So "Ordinary Joe" is basically
it plays with this idea
of what if and how the choices
that we make in our lives
really shaped who we become
and what we become.
And so it plays with the three
iterations of this guy's life.
You see the decision that
he makes right after college
that sends him down
three totally different paths,
depending on what decision
he made that day.
So it's kind of like a choose
your own adventure novel,
except you're watching
the series
and you get
to see how his life plays out,
and it's drastically different
in all three lives.
Like in the clip we just saw, he
becomes an incredibly selfish,
very famous recording artist,
musician.
And in another life,
he ends up having a kid
really early on
with his college sweetheart
and becomes a really young dad.
And he's
a totally different person.
And so you get this to see
how our situations
and the choices we make
really shape us.
And the show's
really fun in that way.
-One thread that ties
all the timelines together
is the connection to Billy Joel.
I'm assuming people who work
on this show must have a deep
abiding love for Mr. Joel
and his work.
-It is a unwavering love
for Mr. Joel.
Russell Friend,
one of our creators --
The two creators are
Garrett Lerner
and Russell Friend,
Russell is from Long Island.
He's from the Oyster Bay Area.
And what I've come to learn --
as I'm from the Midwest,
I'm from Michigan, so this is
this is all new to me --
that if you're from Oyster Bay,
you are like
a diehard Billy Joel guy.
So that's where the whole
Billy Joel throughline
of the of the show comes from.
-Well, there's got to be
something to tie
in three timelines together.
Let's let it be Billy Joel.
And congratulations
on the show.
I'm so glad we finally got a
chance to meet.
Let's do it in person next time.
-Thank you. Same with me, Seth.
Thanks a lot.
-James Wolk, everybody.
"Ordinary Joe"
airs Monday nights at 10 p.m.
here on NBC,
we'll be right back.